Nataly call her angelic voice and
heavenly spirit really were
unforgettable earlier today I sat down
with her sisters Timlin and Casey as
they remembered the woman they loved so
dearly outage and and why did she keep
her illness secret for so long
she was very protective of her family
and her close friends and I don't think
that she wanted people to start feeling
sorry for her I think that she really
really thought and prayed that she would
overcome this nathalie battled health
problems for years once a serious drug
abuser she contracted hepatitis C and
had a kidney transplant in 2009 what was
it like for you spending Christmas with
her we knew that it would be her last so
when we came to the hospital and spent
spent Christmas Eve with her it was it
was a godsend it was her favorite time
of year
she also leaves behind her 38 year old
son Robbie he is having a hard time I
think he's going to it's going to be a
process Natalie's family is keeping her
spirit alive through the Nat King Cole
generation Hope Foundation which
provides music education to kids in need
her good friend Smokey Robinson told
nichelle although natalie is gone her
music will live on Natalie was real she
was good people and one of our greatest
musical icons ever she's gonna live on
and on and on and on because she made
great music and people who knew her
loved her
and on Mary's last day here his host
Natalie came to et to send her off with
styling class so I fix that
I'm forgettable
Natalie being there for my last day
meant the world to me and was one of the
highlights of my career and that was
Natalie big hearted kind classy and
magnificent voice in 2008 though she was
so weak her kidneys were failing you
know what she was always a fighter I'm a
survivor I don't know where I really got
it from but I just I just don't believe
in giving up until you know the fat lady
sings
fat lady hadn't sung yet she really was
one of a kind I'm slightly by the way
you can expect a big celebrity turnout
for her funeral as soon as we get
details we will let you know and Mary as
always it's great having you here we
love you I love you guys too and you and
Nancy always make me feel so welcome
Kevin thank you